Jerusalem just maybe one of history's
most fought over cities from the
Crusades to the israeli-palestinian
conflict the city has seen a lot hey
guys I'm Sunna this is AG plus and today
I want to talk about how at the heart of
the conflict over Jerusalem is the story
of how Israeli occupation has expanded
over the decades Jerusalem is home to
some of the holiest sites to the three
Abrahamic faiths the al-aqsa mosque the
Western Wall and the Church of the Holy
Sepulchre while the israeli-palestinian
conflict has many different dimensions
control over Jerusalem has always been a
really central and symbolic feature of
it and at the heart of the conflict over
Jerusalem is the story of how Israeli
occupation has expanded over decades now
let's rewind a bit to 1947 when a United
Nations Special Committee produced the
first two-state solution a plan to
partition the British Mandate of
Palestine as it was known then into
Jewish and Arab states while Bryn's 1917
Balfour Declaration promising a homeland
prompted migration to Palestine by a
minority of European Jews it was only
after the horrors of the Nazi Holocaust
that the United world body decided to
push ahead with the creation of a
nation-state envisioned in the partition
plan the problem was though that there
were already people living there
Palestinian Muslims and Christians so
the plan was to partition the land into
one country for Palestinians and another
for Jews although Palestinians made up
majority of the population in the land
so who would Jerusalem a city holy to
Christians Jews and Muslims alike belong
to well according to the international
community it would belong to the
international community Jerusalem under
the plan was designated a special
international status to be governed by
the United Nations and while that was
the plan that's not really how things
panned out for the holy city when Israel
declared itself a state in 1948
neighboring Arab armies declared war
it's been called the first arab-israeli
war or as Israel refers to it the war of
independence and the result Israel
captured land a lot more land than the
partition plan had given it the UN
partition had given 55% of territory to
the Jewish state and 45% to the Arab
state and during the 1948 war Israel
gained control of 78% of the total
territory the remaining 22% made up the
West Bank in Gaza which was under the
control of Jordan
Egypt respectively Jerusalem in this
process by the way became a divided City
West Jerusalem fell under Israeli
control and East Jerusalem under
Jordanian this is because toward the end
of the war Jordanian and Israeli
commanders of Delisle tall and mostly on
had drawn up a rough map of the land
divided between them laying the
foundation for what we now call the
green lines for the 1967 borders and why
the 1967 borders well in 1967 tensions
were at an all-time high
between Israel and its neighbor Egypt
which had begun to mobilize troops along
the border Israel preemptively launched
airstrikes against Egypt totally
catching the country off guard and Egypt
led then by pan Arab leader Gamal Abdel
Nasser mobilized Jordan and Syria to
fight back but award didn't actually
last very long in fact the Israeli name
for the war is the six-day war and
Israel came out as victorious and it
captured even more land including East
Jerusalem Israel claimed full
sovereignty over the entirety of
Jerusalem and it's administration of
East Jerusalem is under international
law considered an occupation so when you
hear the term 1967 borders in any
discussion of a two-state solution it
refers to creating an Israeli state and
a Palestinian state based on the
armistice lines of the 1948 war now
despite international law considering
Israeli administration of East Jerusalem
and occupation it hasn't stopped the
government from taking further steps to
entrench its control over the holy city
in fact in 1980 the Israeli Knesset
passed the Jerusalem law in which have
declared the now-infamous line that
Jerusalem complete and United is the
capital of Israel now the international
community did not recognize the law and
despite Israel still considering
Jerusalem its capital not a single
country has its embassy located in
Jerusalem instead you'll find them all
in Tel Aviv including the US Embassy
despite the close relationship between
Israel and the United States the
official American position on Jerusalem
by way of the State Department has been
in line with international law but even
that hasn't stopped American politicians
including three presidents from
supporting Israel's claim to the
entirety of Jerusalem in 1995 US
Congress passed a law requiring that the
American Embassy be moved to Jerusalem
at the same time the law also allowed
the President to sign a waiver every six
months to not move the embassy and even
though both President Bill Clinton and
President George Shelby Bush made camp
promises to relocate the embassy to
Jerusalem they continued signing the
waivers and during his campaign
president Donald Trump made a very clear
promise that he'd also relocate the
embassy to Jerusalem even though his own
Secretary of State doesn't seem too
excited about that prospect in fact even
a lot of US allies have warned against
the move since it would be a de facto
recognition of Israel's claim to all of
Jerusalem court regardless of where
embassies end up the situation on the
ground in Jerusalem isn't changing
anytime soon
especially for Palestinians Palestinians
both Muslims and Christians who live
under Israeli administration are not
given Israeli citizenship instead
they're considered to be permanent
residents meaning they have the same
status as other non Jewish immigrants
even if their families have been there
for generations even if they were born
and raised there and that's a status
that can be revoked resulting in a loss
of residency and that move is part and
parcel of a deliberate policy by Israel
since 1967 to cement its grip on the
city the policy is also designed to
prevent Jerusalem from being a part of
any future Palestinian state and another
big part of the strategy has been
building settlements in East Jerusalem
in violation of international law those
settlements by the way separate
Palestinian parts of Jerusalem from the
West Bank a separation that's also
marked by the building of the wall so
Jerusalem matters not just for religious
reasons but because it is perhaps a
strongest symbol at the heart of the
occupation so Jerusalem is one of those
cities that's always in the news what
else do you guys want to know about it
let us know in the comments and don't
forget to Like subscribe and share